Okay.
Round two.
You dirty freaks.
USTREAM.
Dot.
TV Slash Chow.
MMM.
All right,
we're back.
Um,
so crash,
you've been doing this,
you've been in this tank business longer than that.
I fuck that up.
No,
I didn't.
You've been in this tank business longer than I've known you.
You when,
when did you get started making these fucking things?
Um,
about 15 years at 99.
And what what,
what brought you into that?
Well,
yeah,
I think it was with me.
I was ready to check.
You know,
I used to have a,
I used to have nightclubs and I was in the music industry and I had a,
um,
you know,
narcotics.
I was into drugs and stuff.
I like to do that for,
uh,
you know,
but is it the time was in,
in the 80s and stuff and there's a music industry.
We used to have nightclubs.
They said do a management.
And then I want to do an audio later on back in the 70s where the Stevie ray
Vaughan and stuff like that,
blues clubs in the DC.
And then we went on like in the 80s,
and had like a,
you know,
culture club,
they rhythmics and I've worked with account base and then later on even to do
the audio at Caesar's and I went in the showroom in there and Liberace and on
and on it in a different,
a zine or whatever,
you know,
shows from then I,
uh,
we,
used to tour,
you know,
a little bit and then these gigs and then I got a band going there.
And uh,
we used to open up for one of the bands I was touring with and then we take
great.
So I got interested in like,
oh,
an hour to make some,
it'd be in this,
make it doing music.
And you've got these studios and had 60 of those Hollywood.
And then finally I was done,
you know,
I had enough of these people,
I was strung out on heroin and I used to say,
Oh,
I've had enough.
Not Functional though.
I'm not a stealer.
I don't steal.
I'm a,
I'm a functioning guy back then and I don't steal and I work and I do jobs,
but I used to get,
I used to like to really get high,
you know,
I was,
I was part of what the,
you know what we did,
but so I was finally done with that and I,
I kicked the dope and whenever he went on out there to Vegas from Hollywood,
left my buildings and I built a recording studio.
I've got a ranch out there,
10 miles south of town,
build or build a studio and there was Emma guys come out and we'll do some
recording out there at this a ranch.
I got there and I'm in the back there.
I just built it out of my head now.
No,
there was like an old water thing from what the horses were getting water from
or whatever it was and my head in there and I was working on my voice and when I
pulled my head out,
all of a sudden I,
I know I'm supposed to build these deprivation chambers.
I don't even know what is a deprivation chamber.
It hits.
So you had,
you had like this idea,
Jamie,
keep,
take this down off it.
Just go with the screen.
So we could just see those,
those photos at round before I get distracted sometimes.
Yeah.
Um,
so you just add a nowhere had this idea.
It wasn't even an ideal.
It wasn't an idea cause I didn't even know what it was.
So just hit you.
And it wasn't my voice,
a light or nothing.
It was just all of a sudden I had my head in that thing.
I was that.
And when I pulled my head out,
I knew I'm supposed to build deprivation chambers and get ever people to do it.
I don't know what is a deprivation or nothing.
I just built a recording studio.
I got no interest.
I'm already doing what I wanna do.
I don't need to change a life or I've quit doing what it was that was holding me
up,
you know,
so I was on my path already,
but it hit me so hard.
And at that moment I was relieved of all my previous,
uh,
you know,
like I had a,
you think back and say,
oh,
I used to have this or I used to have that I'd built empires and then collapse
them over the years.
You know,
I worked,
worked really hard and then because too much fun wrecked it every time,
you know,
so I'd been through and at that point in my life he's thinking,
bummer,
you know,
I kept thinking about,
now I'm starting over again and whatever.
And at the moment when I pull my hand out of there,
this no longer affected me at all.
None of my past was.
So you lean into this thing that they use to hold water or water for animals.
Horses probably.
And you look in there and you pull your head out and all of a sudden you have
this mandate,
you have to build sensory deprivation tanks.
So you essentially got a message from God.
I don't believe in God.
Listen,
Pal,
he was talking to you.
Lead them.
If it wasn't God,
who was it?
Anything.
I don't know what it was.
I'm confused.
Does indicate though some sort of superior,
uh,
well think about the move the chain of events that happened.
Now you create that thing,
you know,
you,
you improve upon the existing dynamic,
the existing design rather in a substantial way.
You become obsessed with it.
You and I get hooked up.
We make videos about it.
We started putting it out.
You're doing a podcast now.
More people are finding out about it.
More people are opening these centers.
I get every time I go to a town like it seems there,
if it,
if it's town that has a sensory deprivation tank,
I get these offers to come stop by and check them out and say,
hey,
we started doing it because we heard about it on the podcast.
It's a great way to make a living.
We love floating.
We'd love the benefits of it.
We just want to thank you so much.
That happens.
All the
Tom,
you're in the movie,
man.
You're in the movie.
What happened?
Happened and,
and,
and what's going to happen is yet to be,
because what's coming up still is,
is much larger than what's happened so far with tanks,
with these chambers.
Right?
We think they're going to be ever,
I don't think so.
I,
I'm,
I'm pretty well sure of it at this point.
Cause I,
I have,
uh,
I have a realistic vision of the situation and I'm convinced at this point that
indeed it is going to work.
You know,
and I don't know the,
how it all is going to turn out of course,
but I think that we're having a chance now and that's why this situation is so
important to me.
This,
this just infection and this electrical and all these,
these features that have to do with health and safety.
So this can become a safe,
healthy and uh,
a,
uh,
just like restaurants.
Just like anything else that involves cleanliness.
This is very important.
It's a public service.
And then for you,
what's important is that it protects the benefits of this service where all of
the negative aspects of it are eliminated with foresight thinking about it in
advance.
And I think that's super important and I really,
I really commend you on that.
And you also have these really fascinating ideas about how to go about that.
I mean your,
your,
your systems,
the cleanliness and all of the ozone,
the filters and the,
the,
the sensitivity of the filters.
It's all incredible stuff.
Incredibly detailed stuff.
Yeah,
we've spent a lot of time keeping getting better.
We're just now finishing up with a whole nother bunch of stuff
through that.
It's one thing after the next thing I see when I first started this I was using,
apart from,
you know,
this or that or whatever,
there was like no parts for anything that you were trying to make.
So you have to like really try to figure out how to improvise.
Whereas now though,
all of every single component that we use is made for us.
We have very specific providers.
All of this stuff that we've refined over the years,
these containers,
everything.
It's all very specific cause there's a,
an an unbelievable amount of problems.
What's that term?
Bespoke,
right?
The custom made is that what be spoke his talk?
I,
I believe that is [inaudible] in the last one.
No,
no.
I want to learn these bowling alone.
That's fine.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sport.
That's what it means.
Um,
made to order.
Yeah.
That's what order,
right?
Yeah.
So essentially these parts and components did not exist until you came along
with designing these new devices for chambers.
I figured out how to get them all to work together.
Yeah.
It's been,
uh,
you know,
to get it to go on and get it off all the electrical.
I mean,
it's been a,
it's been okay.
It's been fun.
You know,
it's getting like to the point now to where we're glad that we finally are on
the other side of all this stuff and that it is a valid system that the system
now,
uh,
demands,
acknowledgement.
We put it in there and they can't say,
hey,
you can't do this here.
That's not true.
We could put one of our devices anywhere and the authorities will allow it
because it's done to code.
That's why when these places they're trying to get through these trouble,
they're looking for an exemption or a,
uh,
was the other word.
They got variance these different,
uh,
things they try to get.
Also,
it's not a swimming pool so you don't have to have any code or whatever.
These things aren't cool thing is we pools have code,
right?
And because this isn't a pool doesn't mean it shouldn't have code.
That just means it should have a set of codes that are specifically designed for
this environment,
which is what this stuff is here.
This,
uh,
CCS standard here that we have,
you see it,
it's all that stuff there that you read through this and this is the reality of
the direction that the industry is going in.
That the authorities are aware and,
and then they're not stupid.
They understand what liability is.
They,
they can't say,
hey,
go ahead.
It's okay.
We don't care.
And they can't turn a blind eye on this anymore because it's
brought to their attention now.
Well,
it's also been brought to their attention that there,
there's a lot going on right now where people were being investigated for,
for things like the doctor Oz stuff.
We've got all weight loss shit that's out there and you know,
all this self help industry like things along the lines of isolation tanks.
It can be incredibly damaging if these things become as popular as you and I
think they will be.
And the filtration systems aren't good and people have nightmare stories.
Exactly what actions it won't survive and survive.
That's what happened.
We get grossed out by it.
Yeah.
Came out,
these things were not capable of dealing with an aids.
Even these,
these,
uh,
parasites like cryptosporidium that,
that it'll take 10 days and chlorine to deactivate a Giardia.
That's,
that's,
you know,
day in chlorine and bromine and these are not effective methods to deal with.
Well that,
and that's something that people would consider it for these tanks,
chlorine.
And it's,
it's,
it's actually bad for your skin to sit in it like that.
It's not,
it's not healthy for you like the skin.
Like when you go into a chlorinated pool and you'd go into like a public pool
specialty that's heavily corn in,
it hurts your eyes
at the end.
She was system.
It is your breathing it and when it's breaking down and an action with this
other materials,
these methane's and the,
like I said,
it's creating a polyphony of toxic byproducts,
then that need to be eradicated.
You can't just keep,
that's where you go to these places.
They said,
hey,
how often are you switching that water out of there?
I was like,
Oh,
you know this guy on that thing with the Hamilton said,
oh,
every four months and you're going,
huh?
So today you're going to take h he says it's expensive,
don't want to do it.
It's expensive.
So today you take $800 a year money and throw it down the drain.
But yesterday it was just fine to charge somebody come in here and stew around
in that stuff.
And I mean it isn't right.
You mean it should be a regulatory agency that demands,
you know,
certain level of a,
of cleanliness.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean it's important.
Well,
it's important too that there's,
there's ways that people can avoid the negative aspects entirely.
Figure that out,
do it,
and don't have fast that don't put people at risk.
But as I said before was we were talking about before,
this is one of the things that I wanted to get into.
Um,
what about like a commercial version of it,
a non commercial version of a home version of it.
A version where you know,
that's just going to be you using it.
You know that you're not going to do anything stupid.
You're going to have to take a shower before you go in.
You're not gonna urinate in it.
You're not going to,
it's only yours.
Like you wouldn't need all that other extra jazz if it was only yours.
Correct.
Well,
W W we would want to do is make sure that whatever we build is built to code.
We don't want to put stuff into circulation.
That's not code where the signage didn't happen to somebody.
Liability issues.
Like if they,
if we cheaped out on something and it made it and then they would,
you know,
okay.
But listen,
hold on a second.
You're saying cheaped out,
but I don't necessarily think it's cheaping out.
It's only cheaping out if you don't know what's going to into that water.
If you know what's going into that water because it's only yours.
It's not cheaping out at all.
It's like,
do you need to overburden your system?
Do you need to make it so it's unbelievably stringent?
It removes all the path.
Just no,
you're not.
No one's going in there,
but you.
Yeah.
If it's just,
don't you think that that would be that not only that'd be totally acceptable.
It would be ethical as long as you tell the people what to do.
Well,
I could agree with that.
You know the,
the,
the issue is with us though,
is that people,
they're there,
they're going to take that,
that that system that we said just for your home and they're going to put it
into a commercial space.
Right.
But once that these laws and all of these standards are put into place,
then certainly then we might be interested in saying,
okay,
now here's how it could be done.
That that would be less,
uh,
effective say then the commercial version.
But first we would have first,
what we're,
we're very diligent about is to establish these guidelines in the beginning.
Not just say,
oh well yeah,
some of our stuff does this or that.
It's like all of it does,
it's certified.
It's,
it's perfect as it is now.
But the rest of it is like,
okay,
we could do that,
but it wouldn't be,
you know what it is that we've taken so much time and effort to,
to get,
right now we know all the other components,
the less expensive ones,
let's say.
Right.
And we could do that.
But what I'm saying is the only reason why you need all those expensive
components cause you're dealing with more than one human being.
Right.
If it's me,
that's the one human being,
I'm,
I'm completely okay with taking super clean actions on it.
Yeah,
me too.
Wouldn't that be like,
um,
I like to have the best.
Yeah,
I know.
But for someone who lives,
you know,
in a,
in a modest way and can't afford to spend a massive amount,
is there a way,
like,
I know that there's this new thing that they're coming out with intent.
Yeah.
What do you think of that?
Well,
it's a shower curtain on a,
on an aluminum frame,
you know,
which is,
uh,
you know,
I don't know how they're going to keep that stuff from a hardening up.
There's a lot of things I don't know about.
I know,
and I don't want to salt in the water.
Yeah.
Right.
And now the,
I don't know how they're going to keep that somewhere without getting a hard,
I don't know how it's not going to dissipate out of there,
you know,
I haven't really studied into it,
but I'm aware of certain limitations that occur just in general when you're
dealing with this material.
Right.
And do you think that perhaps some of these other designs are made from people
that do not have a long term history,
a long time history in this sort of a business?
Like they don't understand exactly what's involved.
What the like I remember,
uh,
the thing about,
the dude who worked for somebody,
he had encountered all the bullshit before he knew about when engine seized up.
He knew the salt content was too high and it would fuck with the spa engines you
were placed.
He knew,
he knew in advance what it was.
Probably when we talked on the phone what the issues were and he would come home
and fix them.
So you think a lot of these folks,
they just sort of getting into tanks now and then they go,
hey,
I've got an idea.
But they're not foreseeing the potential hazards or issues that would come from
these things.
Yes,
exactly.
Good explanation.
That's a,
this,
I don't think that they care.
They're the ones that I'm aware of.
Some of these guys.
I don't
know.
I know,
cause I,
I try not to,
to,
to get involved with these people because we're on our own page.
We are trying to get,
we're not,
we're not trying,
we're doing it.
We,
we,
we were moving forward in a,
in a direction.
I understand what I mean.
You're aware of these all these little companies that are coming up.
And the good thing is that it's making people aware of tanks like a Kickstarter.
You know,
somebody sent me a Kickstarter for that,
that Zen tank thing,
and I looked at and I was like,
I don't know if I can retweet this.
I don't know enough about it.
I don't know if it's good enough.
It's bad.
I don't know if it's a good idea.
Maybe on that Google,
on your computer when you have the Yahoo search motor or whatever it is there
and say I saw it on the Yahoo,
it said,
oh,
San tent or whatever.
It's interesting.
So it's,
the public has a somewhat of a interest in it.
Like I say,
the e news is doing a,
uh,
some,
series on,
uh,
actors and how they get into a peak performance or whatever it is,
like this and that.
And they want to include us in that,
uh,
in that frame of this type of activities,
that laboratory deprivation.
Yeah.
You know,
how many celebrities use semiprivate sensory deprivation tanks?
Is there a lot?
There was more and more.
We have them coming in more now.
Yeah,
there's some that you know,
that are very,
uh,
it's very,
it's pretty cool to it,
you know,
and there are those good people as well.
They're the ones that come in that are famous or whatever.
They're,
they're never like a big,
uh,
you know,
it's me or anything like that.
They come in low,
you wreck,
you know,
uh,
that's why I come in and dude,
Elton John Sunglasses,
big fucking feather hats.
It's got to come in big [inaudible] world to the occasion where you gators
there.
But the people then that,
that,
that are,
so what I'm saying though is it,
it's becoming more and more of a main stream on coming,
more and more popular and people becoming more and more aware of it.
And I know a lot of fighters use at Diego Sanchez.
I'm really big on it.
Jeremy Stevens,
who we talked about earlier,
he loves it.
There's a lot of fighters that come in and not,
it was a very close fight,
but he did not win.
But it was,
uh,
it was very close and it was very good.
It was an excellent fight.
It was really close.
Like at the end,
I believe it was a split decision and at the end,
uh,
we were going,
man,
who knows.
But,
uh,
I think the right guy,
one,
I think cubs wants him won the fight,
but it was,
like I said,
it was super,
super close.
They both put it all in all it was great.
It was wild fight to watch.
These guys are so skilled that that's been about kick with a guy kicked him in
the chin.
I watched you walk out on a little clip and you're walking out on it.
This is long time ago and as you're walking,
you don't even stop walking and you jump around and kick the guy.
I think he kicked him in the chest or something and he goes out and immediately,
I mean,
it was like,
it wasn't even,
you didn't even stop walking.
And then that guy from,
uh,
what,
what is that?
Uh,
there's a law and order show.
The vault guy that's like the captain or whatever he is.
He was telling the story about you and him.
They are going through New York and there's these,
uh,
who would love this,
right?
It was like four or five or somebody say,
so.
It's,
Joe's says,
what are you talking into?
A microphone crashed.
Sorry about that Charles.
Uh,
Joe says to him,
I forgot it.
Do you know what the guy is?
The bald law and order guy.
He's like the in floor.
Yeah.
Said he said that you guys were there and Joe looks over and he says,
Hey,
can,
can you take one of these guys?
And he goes,
oh,
okay.
I'm sorry Joe jumped up.
And this never happens in New York.
I didn't knock anybody out.
This is a completely fabricated story and you are in New York.
There's some who'd love to get your name because you talking about me,
I'm trying to happen.
Did Not happen.
Never happened.
See,
this is the story he told me was he was,
cause he might've been on pain pills.
Are you sure it's the right guy on Ambien?
I don't know if it's the right,
but you just never had a problem.
Like,
I did not beat up anybody in New York.
Never kicked a guy down.
The,
the ones ran off.
I haven't been told me,
no,
I haven't been in any sort of a physical altercation.
So I was in high school.
Really?
Yeah.
You never did.
You never have to get into a situation with some guy.
Get him to lippy mouth and you've got to put them up there.
A guy on fear factor that I had it grab.
But once I grabbed him,
shut up and I just grabbed him and held on to him,
grabbed his neck,
but he thought it might hurt him.
I just,
he was just too dangerous.
He had hit some people before he had thrown his wife down on a television show
and he had attacked a counselor on another television show and we,
they had warned us before he came on the show that he was like,
he was very,
he was a contestant background.
He was a celebrity.
Um,
one of those realities,
celebrities,
he had been on a reality show with his wife.
Oh,
this is the new one.
It was an old fear factor.
Was it the head reality shows back then?
Oh yeah,
man,
sure.
They had survivorman started in 2000 I want to say like 2001 or survivor did
rather 2001 and this guy was on the amazing race,
which I think was like 2004 or three or something like that.
Yeah.
I mean they've had those for a long time.
Grabbed them,
just get them just to chill.
I thought it was going to hit me.
He kept getting in my face.
I pushed him away.
He got my face again.
I was like,
I'm not going to let,
the problem with someone hitting you is it's really hard to see.
They're going to hit you.
If they sucker punch you by the time you react,
you've already been hit.
You know,
it's the reaction times that people have are way slower than action times action
times are way faster.
So if someone decides to hit you and you don't see a comment,
it can be very dangerous.
And when someone keeps invading your space and they're,
they're not listening,
they're violent,
they're angry,
they're spitting your face or screaming.
If you just let a guy hit you,
you know,
the first punch is one of the most important aspects of any sort of an
altercation.
You get hit,
you get hurt,
damaged,
and then someone could fuck you up.
You know,
you've gotta be really careful trying to regroup.
Yeah,
so when someone,
these violating all the laws of engagement and he's also,
he's showing himself to be very,
very dumb about physical altercation because he keeps coming forward.
I pushed him away from me and he keeps coming forward again,
like something's going to happen.
If you keep doing this and you're not thinking about it,
you're not thinking about what the repercussions are.
You don't even know how to fight and yet you still,
you already towards them.
But not just that I'm looking at is physical frame.
I'm like,
he's just,
he's frail.
There's nothing there that's like dangerous.
There's no explosive movement.
He's,
he's spitting,
he's yelling,
he's red in the face.
It's all emotional.
It's got to run out of gas and five seconds.
If I grab him,
I'm just thinking all these things like,
but I don't want him to hit me.
That's the only one time though.
That's the only on time on television.
I mean I've gotten in arguments with people before,
but I'm a nice person man.
For the most part I can avoid most bullshit,
but I didn't kick anybody in New York.
I think he said,
he said there's the other ones ran off.
You asked him if he could handle one of them.
He said,
yeah,
I don't know what to [inaudible].
I don't know what to say.
Oh,
I don't know what you remember.
I Dunno who was on Ambien.
I Dunno who is a third.
I don't know neither to be honest with you.
But yeah,
I wouldn't do that thought about though is that a lot of these people,
I think that,
you know,
once you stand up they take the scatter off,
sometimes choke on the guys contact.
That will usually stop.
You should always avoid altercation if you can do it.
Any physical altercation,
if you can avoid it,
please do.
You're always better off people.
Cooler heads prevail.
People relax,
they calm down,
they calmed down and get over a situation that could have resulted in a murder.
I mean that happens all the time where it's just like people escalate and to get
to this point and they make irrational decisions and they're super violent and
then they go and do something really dumb.
You know,
it happens all the time.
People,
they get caught up in their emotions,
they get caught up in their anger,
they get caught up in their primal chimpanzee rage and they just fuck up and
they do something terrible.
That's why how people who love each other wind up killing each other.
I mean,
where,
how could that even be rational?
How could you ever kill someone that you used to love?
And it all boils down to some of the same issues that we were talking about
earlier.
People don't have releases.
They don't have a release for their aggression.
They don't have a release for their frustration.
They don't have a release for the energy that their body continues to make.
They have all this food they're taking in their body,
their body's getting fat because they're not exercising it.
So this is all these imbalances and everybody's uncomfortable and people were
agitated,
they're agitated and easily irritated.
And is all about personal maintenance and it's all an issue of personal
maintenance,
whether it's by taking yoga classes or what you and I like to do by getting into
the tank or what some folks like to do,
they just collect to go for an evening job.
I know a lot of people that say that they,
they'd go for a jog,
like Jamie's big Jogger,
you go for a run and it clears your mind when it's over you.
Just things that seem so important.
20 minutes ago they don't seem that important anymore.
An hour ago you were sweating all these different things and now you're like,
ah,
and the greater perspective,
everything's going to be okay.
I was just caught up in a wave of momentum of emotions and anxiety and
oftentimes you can alleviate a big chunk of those just with physical exercise.
There's like they say that physical exercise is as effective as antidepressants
when it comes to making people feel better.
Yes.
That physical exercise for a lot of folks is the recipes.
What I mean comedy writer and he comes in and he says that,
what's
his name?
I don't remember his name.
I forgot his name.
That you want to be writer guy?
Yeah.
He's calling me right back.
He goes for a walk though.
He doesn't even know run.
He says he runs,
he doesn't even like to run.
But when he goes out and he runs,
it creates a,
uh,
a mental framework that he uses to write with.
Yes.
So he'll go out and just go for a run to create the mental mind frame that he's
going to work off of is a material with,
yeah.
Not to get the physical,
uh,
benefits.
Right.
I thought,
whoa.
That's a interesting,
uh,
because I know sometimes I'll riding my bike,
some stuff comes into my head that I would,
oh wow.
I didn't think about that.
You know,
so I guess when you're in this,
you know,
exercising mode too,
your,
your physical stuff is taken care of.
Well,
sure.
You're also,
you're pumping your body filled with blood.
You're accelerating all your processes.
You're getting all your hormones going,
you're getting all your endorphins going.
Your body's pumping,
you know,
you're flushing out your system.
Everything's moving.
You're sweating.
So you're sweating toxins out of your system.
Allegedly.
I don't like when people talk about that because usually they don't know what
the fuck they're talking about and I'm getting rid of all the toxins.
Are you really?
Are you just sweating?
And now what's happening here?
So I'm not really sure if I should say that,
but that's a lot of it.
It's a,
you know,
it's a exercise
that allows the mind to,
uh,
release a little bit or at least come down perhaps when it's full.
The physical,
uh,
situation is requiring more of you then,
and then your mind is like freed up from creating problems too.
It's the battery thing we were talking about earlier too.
It's the,
your body stores up all this energy and you don't have a release.
Some folks never have and any sort of an explosive release like months,
weeks,
days,
there's nothing,
it never happens.
They have no,
no release.
So their bodies just like Wah,
you know,
it's designed for all these different things that doesn't get used for.
It's designed so that you can do manual labor.
It's designed so that you could hunt for food so that you could gather and farm.
It's designed to be sturdy when required to be and when you don't require it to
be,
it gets uncomfortable.
You know?
And that's,
that's the issue that a lot of people face in this weird modern world that we've
created because we don't,
we don't give the body what it really truly needs.
I said Homo Stacy's thing supposed to the natural state or something like that
where,
and I think that one of the fascinating things about the tank is that it allows
a very unusual type of relaxation.
It also is an incredible way to absorb magnesium into your body like magnesium,
which is an important mineral.
It gets absorbed through your body through those salts.
It's like Epson salts is one of the best ways to get into your body.
You feel better when you lie in that thing.
You feel invigorated.
I lie in that thing for a couple of hours and I feel like I just slept like a
really good eight hours sleep.
Like Ah,
such a good thing.
So good chambers are so good.
That's what the people that the,
what's interesting is that people
like it when they come in and they do it,
they go,
oh,
you know,
that was a very low percentage of uh,
not that we ever ask or anything,
but most people say,
wow,
wow.
You know,
there is a,
it's such a positive,
uh,
learning and uh,
the downside,
you know,
I don't even know what it is.
I don't think there's a downside,
but I have had people come to me that,
that we're in a poorly set up tank.
I'm like,
this one guy came to me and says,
Hey,
I tried to do it,
but I was sweating.
I was like,
well,
you're in a badly set up tank.
You're not supposed to sweat you.
Almost a forced to feel slightly cool.
Yeah.
Just to get in somehow slightly cool.
And if you're sweating at all,
it's just the temperature.
The water's too high and that can happen.
It's happened to me before.
I've had my temperature set wrong or for whatever reason it gets warmer
outsides.
I emailed you about that recently.
I said,
leave the door open for awhile.
Let some of the heat out,
you know that number down one notch or just left it.
I left it.
Did you want us to take it?
Oh,
it's too late.
It doesn't matter.
I can do that.
So yeah,
but it's um,
if it's set up correctly,
it's a,
an amazing thing and it should be something that everyone,
at least at one point in your life recognizes or experiences because I think
that it's,
it's an alien environment that doesn't exist anywhere else in the world.
If you could take a pill that could give you the experience that you get when
you're full blown in the tank,
you know how that,
you know,
that feeling that you get when you're fully relaxed,
when you've completely let go like an hour in or something like that where
everything is just so chill and your mind is in this like incredible place and
you're essentially just breathing and floating when you hit that moment,
man,
if you could get a pill that could put people in that state,
it would be like ecstasy.
People would be like trading it in the black market.
They'd be like,
this is amazing,
dude.
The feeling that gives you like the world goes away,
dude,
you don't feel your body.
The world goes away and you're alone with your mind and an empty room.
You'd be like,
whoa.
People would freak out if it felt good.
It would be like,
that's the craziest drug ever.
Yeah,
man.
It's freaky,
Bro.
It's so illegal though.
If you get caught with it,
you're dead.
It's completely black chow forever.
While it lost,
it is like a drug in its effects,
but it's completely natural.
Completely safe.
Completely.
I mean,
I guess he could get addicted to it because I think a person could get pretty
much addicted to anything.
Right.
You know,
if it's worth doing,
it's worth overdoing
people.
Say that about jerking off.
Then they get blisters on their deck.
Yeah,
the locusts coming until you got to worry about the locus.
Then you got to worry about,
you know,
people get that way with gambling people.
I mean people get addicted to bunk off a lot of things that aren't physically
addictive as far as like the cellular level.
But do you get addicted to those rushes that you get?
You get a dictation.
Can we get addicted to fighting with their spouse?
It's a lot of people that just can't help it.
They have these seesaw battles within their relationships when they get mad and
yell at each other and then they recover and they love each other so much better
because of the fact that they've gone through this,
this almost neuro chemicals that we're at.
We get upset and then we got,
we get
a hit from that.
Interesting.
We get bored,
you know,
we're designed to go uh,
wild through the jungle,
banging each other like monkeys.
We don't do that anymore.
So we get bored.
So the way we keep it exciting is start fights
at all,
upset,
make up with each other.
This is what I love about the tank is that it gives you the chance to sort of
step back and see stuff like that.
It gives you a chance to step back and see like your whole life and to be alone
with your mind.
Oh,
he alone with your mind to just really get a good look at what the fuck's going
on.
It's such a good place to go to.
Did you beat then?
Cause it's like the regular world is just loaded with stuff now.
It's like you're constant in order,
just like unplugged,
not answer the phone or not,
not have anything going on at all.
It's so very,
uh,
complex,
complex to get yourself somewhere where you almost have to like leave and go on
a vacation or something.
But in there you could just,
you could just get in there and close the door and then take yourself out of
whatever it was that w w was.
Where do you want it to leave from?
You know,
and uh,
it can't come back later.
A better prepared to,
uh,
to deal with the situation that it might've been,
you know?
Yeah.
I,
I agree.
And I think it's just,
it's so interesting to me that this slipped through the cracks for decades.
That somehow or another people forgot about this and it was one of those things.
It was incredibly fringe when I came upon it.
Um,
I went to a place called soothing solutions.
It's still open in Burbank and uh,
they have those Samadi tanks and they do a great job taking care of them and
they have a shower right there.
They have a real good set up.
And The lady that ran it was super nice,
but she was like,
it was on the verge of going under.
Like there wasn't that many people that were using those tanks.
It was just,
it was a pretty rare,
it wasn't like the super popular thing.
And I remember the first time I did it there,
I was like,
this is fucking bananas.
How is this not something that everybody's talking about everywhere you go?
And I,
I questioned her about it and I questioned other people about it and then I
would ask people,
have you heard about it?
And I was stunned by how few people in the psychedelic community didn't do it.
We're going to sell thousands of them.
Ken has never done it.
I'm getting there going,
this is such an,
I don't think
you're going to everybody.
When I first did it and I started doing it going,
this is something that it,
it's Graham Hancock had never done it and I know it.
He's supposed to come to my house and do it.
I was going to send them to you to do it.
Next time he's in,
he's in America.
I'm fucking,
I'm dragging them to one of those things.
It's like,
how can you go around?
He traveled all the way to the jungle to do Iowasca Com.
It's right here.
Sit Down,
didn't do himself really good.
He's amazing,
intuitive like that.
He's a great,
great guy too.
Just a beautiful human being and being somebody that really has a lot,
a lot in him.
Fascinating,
honest,
inquisitive to take chances in,
even if he's incorrect.
Occasionally with some of these ideas,
the ones that he's been correct about,
it's pretty mind blowing.
Some of the implications of some of the things that he's discovered and what
things are,
we were talking about this on the phone or the on the car right up here that go
Beckley Tepi situation where they've discovered this incredible,
uh,
stone ruins from 14,000 years ago.
And this is something that they just didn't even know existed before.
They didn't know there was a culture 14,000 years ago that was capable of
building something like this.
And because of the fact that it was covered up 14,000 years ago,
they're pretty sure that it was built at least that long ago,
perhaps even longer.
It's covered up on purpose.
It was covered up on pertinent and they said,
I think they explained how the arc,
and this is all mainstream archeology folks,
this isn't some weird fringe shit.
This is a,
I mean,
pretty much completely agreed upon by all these different scientists that at
some point around 12,000 years ago,
they covered all of the stone structures.
And it's an enormous stone,
uh,
structure complex of these concentric circles.
And there's these weird three dimensional carvings that are into the stone
columns.
They're huge.
We're very integrated,
very difficult to do.
Especially back then when they thought that people were essentially just hunters
and gatherers,
which is,
you know,
they didn't think that people had built cities back then.
So 14,000 years ago,
someone or 12,000 plus years ago,
someone had had the ability to do this that we were unaware of until this
discovery.
And this discovery wasn't even made until like then I think the nineties
eighties or nineties someone found one of these stones and they started
uncovering it.
And to this day they've only uncovered like 5% why isn't that a focus?
Well,
it is.
It's just slowly but surely.
Well,
it's only 5% uncovered,
but it's,
it's a focus of us.
Why?
Why is it society like informed about Kim Kardashians acids?
Huge.
And a lot of people think it's fake.
That's it.
Her dog has got a,
he's got his paws.
Something's wrong.
There's something wrong with the dog.
What are the challenges?
The shoe shoe.
Dot.
Yeah.
Well,
it's mainstream television.
Mainstream media is a lot of is,
you know,
it's,
it's a business and it's based on the,
the base humans that,
the amount of numbers look,
I've talked to a lot of people that work for Papa razzies that work for like TMZ
that work for these people.
They're just regular people that are a part of this system that they get some
money out of.
And the,
the get some money out of the system exists because people are curious as to
what Brittany Spears is up to.
They're curious as to,
you know,
how Kanye West is going to deal with Jimmy Kellum making fun of them.
I,
the people just get super obsessed by this stuff and there's a business and
feeding that obsession.
So all these people that don't take themselves away from the television and
don't get into an isolation tank and don't take a yoga and don't consciously
choose to not inundate their mind with silly nonsense.
Instead,
if they just took a,
a broader path,
took a a wider view,
took a,
a more sensible to their life,
you know,
I think we would see less and less of that stuff.
You know it exists because there's a void because there's a reason for it
because it's interesting to people.
It could be a fad.
Maybe if people continue to,
you know,
get smarter along the course that we looked at earlier in the podcast,
the court,
not the courtship of Eddie's father,
but of um,
leave it to beaver.
We look at,
leave it to beaver and then look at things that we see on television today and
the sophistication level of the media that we produce.
The,
there,
the artwork that we produce is pretty intense.
The growth amount,
it's pretty intense.
So I think that that is just the evidence that people are becoming more
sophisticated overall.
There's still going to be plenty of idiots.
There always will be.
There's always going to be people that resist.
There's always going to be people that are like involved in religious cults.
There's going to be people that are ideologues that have these insane
ideologies.
There's always going to be that.
But I think that overall things are getting more sophisticated.
People are becoming more aware of people becoming more smart.
Don't you think?
I'm,
I'm hoping for that.
And I believe that that's,
that's probably correct.
And the tanks part of that in some what tanks
can help a person.
I mean if everybody,
you know,
and like I say,
they put them in these schools,
help these kids,
you know,
the
defined themselves.
You know,
that that's very important for people that to have that opportunity in that,
that option to take and uh,
turn out how they want to be based on what it is that they think that,
how they want to be.
You know what I mean?
He said do it because of your own reasons.
Yeah.
And know what those reasons are.
And that's one of the things about meditation,
whether it's TM or whether it's yoga,
whether it's going into a tank.
When you're alone with your thoughts,
you get an idea of what your thoughts actually are.
If you live your life,
just act and constantly on the momentum of other people's expectations of you
wanting to be liked by these other people.
You can run into a trap and you,
you,
you set up a life that you didn't really want.
You're fucked.
You're,
you're,
you're trapped in this situation where you have a mortgage,
you've got credit card bills,
you've got student loans,
you have to pay,
you have a bunch of shit going on.
Do you have to continue to feed and all that.
And especially if you have a family and you have to feed them,
oh my goodness.
Then you are fully locked in.
You can't take any chances whatsoever.
And oftentimes people make the mistake of getting stuck and it is just a
tactical mistake.
Just like it would be a mistake if you got stuck on a video game just like it
would be a mistake if you followed a map incorrectly and you get stuck in the
woods,
you're life is certainly some sort of a journey.
It's certainly some sort of a journey and we have to all be aware that when
we're making journeys,
we're not going to always make the right steps and sometimes you have to back up
and try again.
And if you're in a position where you can't back up and try again,
you've trapped herself and the system will set out honeypots for to get trapped
in the system will set out the ideas of retirement,
the ideas of the golden years providing you benefits,
providing you a healthy work environment.
Why?
Well,
because they want people to work for them.
They don't want people to realize their own dreams and escape those.
That's a fucking pain in the ass.
You got to hire more people and train them and they want to set it up so that
you stick around,
stick around in some sort of an unsatisfying world.
It's up to you to see that video game problem,
to see that issue as it comes up on the map and know,
and I think this is a right turn to see all the problems that could potentially
lay in front of you and calculate your,
your future and then also look around all the people that didn't do it and look
at the misery that they're in and learn that you don't want to be like them.
And then look at the people that have kind of taken chances and navigated their
way.
What did they do differently than you?
When?
What would objectivity do they have that maybe you lack?
What insight into their own mistakes?
Are they willing to delve into that?
You're not that you step back and go,
you know,
I don't,
I just don't,
I just don't want to look at myself that closely.
But the person who's able to look at themselves the closest it's going to get
the more rational
results.
Well put,
you know,
cause you're your own architect,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Your turnout,
how you sort of,
I want to be like Shaquille O'Neal,
Shit's not going to happen.
You know,
if you want it to be like tall black guy.
Yeah,
that's really the odds are slim.
Can you imagine if you could imagine they found out that the secret is real,
that you could just become whatever you want.
So if you thought hard enough about being a giant,
you would just start growing.
If you thought hard enough about being a woman,
you would just turn into a woman.
Like people like look at you,
like is something going on crash?
He'd just be like,
AH,
well I've been thinking a lot about living my life as a woman,
so I just started to become a woman and he could just do it like from a cellular
level and the unconsciously totally catch us.
What's going on here with this?
That's ridiculous.
I'm talking about completely consciously.
Isn't that the idea behind like the,
the secret?
Did you get like,
um,
when that whole,
uh,
the secret thing was going on and what the bleep do we know when people started
really getting into the idea of manifesting your own reality with your
imagination,
did you get a lot more people coming into the tank centers looking for a place
to do that was probably like kind of in the people maybe started to,
uh,
that uh,
group,
uh,
what's it called?
Group consciousness or collect collective consciousness.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't really like that and I don't like that you Animoto stuff about the
water,
having a personality or whatever it is that bullshit.
I have a dark field microscope and I studied,
you know,
a bit about water and I yell at it or I'm nice to it and I can't tell the
difference.
You know,
I haven't tried it.
Yeah.
Yo,
you know you're a rotten and it doesn't seem to affect the water under my
microscope.
But he does the freezing.
I don't know how he did it,
but I said,
what is it called?
The message in the water?
Well it's Yamamoto.
He's a scientist that uh,
suggest that uh,
the water is it like we're water sort of I think as the premise premises that if
you're nice to water,
water's nice.
And they said if you're nice to,
they're nice.
I think it's something,
it's called hidden messages in water and it's all pretty fascinating.
But a lot of people think it's total bullshit.
Scientists think that.
Yeah,
but those are the ones he got to listen to van.
Cause all these other people,
they're seeing ghosts and shit.
You know,
the problem is the scientists to the one,
they're an analyzing shit and looking for actual results.
Whereas the people that are like really into spirituality and channelers and
they're looking to find it
very specific result,
they're not looking to just measure these things.
Do you know it's fun.
You ever done that thing with the muscle testing and they push on your arm,
they put the little medallion on near the test lumen medallion or whatever,
and they say,
Oh,
you know,
you're,
this is a Tesla technology or now it's so okay,
they put the little wristband,
little whatever it is.
So I could never understand how that works.
Does it make any sense to me?
So one day it's guy shows up and he says,
yeah,
okay,
let me try this then.
So I have a desk behind me with a towel on it.
So now actually there's a proximity thing.
You gotta be within 10 feet of this thing or something or still has an effect.
So I said,
okay,
what is this thing again?
It's like a medallion,
medallion Medallia or a ring or a second.
Yeah.
They say somethings about Tesla Technology and they put your arm up and they
pushed down on your arm to see that's all bullshit.
Those are Kearney tricks and understand how it was worded.
So I took the thing and I said,
okay,
here,
watch this.
Took the table behind me,
I'm going to have it in my hand or not.
We put it behind my back and either put it up on the table underneath the towel
or I had it my hand.
And when I came back then all the tests were off.
The guy had not a clue how to manipulate the test.
So yeah.
Oh,
so he didn't know if you had it on you.
So then he started doing all this Carney tricks and it didn't,
he couldn't commit to them cause it didn't work.
I had to do,
was trying to produce right with me.
He did it to my,
uh,
my cohost in the UFC and he was believing in it.
He had one arm shit.
He was telling me,
you got to try this,
it's amazing.
And I was like,
what is it?
And the guy goes,
well,
let me explain it to you.
It's all about Polaris,
you know,
start to use it all.
These weren't that polarity.
Magnetism is all about fucking Voodoo.
He's telling me all this stuff.
And then he said,
uh,
this,
this thing when you put on your risk and to make you stronger.
And I go,
really?
And he goes,
yeah.
So he goes,
all right,
um,
well I'm want you to do this.
And he was like,
putting it made me put my arm out right.
Then he goes,
okay,
now resist me.
You know,
and I,
and I resisted him.
And then he's like,
all right,
you're not supposed to be able to resist that.
I was like,
well look man,
you making a mistake,
you've got bad leverage pushing debt.
You're trying to push down on my arms.
You're have a big enough,
I can hold my arms out there.
Like that lift though.
Yeah,
I lift weights.
The shit ain't gonna work.
And then he goes,
all right,
now I want you to put this on,
you know,
like,
tell me if you feel like stronger.
I go,
I'm not any stronger.
You're not going to get you to be stronger from a fucking little rubber band
around my wrist.
This is ridiculous.
I go,
you're standing in a different position.
you're doing it differently.
You were trying to get closer to me before and now you're doing it further away
from me,
which you know you have less leverage.
This is stupid.
I was like,
this is dumb as fuck man.
Parlor trick to got mad at me,
man.
He really upset at me.
His face started getting red.
I go,
listen man,
there's no scientific basis for any of this shit.
He goes,
well,
a hundred thousand hours for each can't be wrong.
It turns out they were wrong.
Turns out they sued.
It.
Turns out there's a class action lawsuit and all those fucking people got their
money back.
I mean,
he's like a,
it's a big deal.
It's a parlor trick.
Total Horse Shit.
But I talked to fucking athletes that swore.
Yeah,
worked.
They do that.
The people believed it.
That's why like you said,
it was the chamber though,
is that like they do all those a hoax or this,
they tried this,
they tried to acupressure and they do these shows on TV and they try to,
uh,
you know,
just credit,
uh,
these,
natural,
uh,
well you can't discredit the chamber.
They have never been able to,
to come up.
Wouldn't they want to,
first of all,
it's,
it's so natural.
It's so natural and so positive and you look at,
it's so ingenious and it's designed 10 effect with Epsom salts
does something,
it helps you do something with yourself.
And I mean,
what else is there that does that hardly
and it's super relaxing,
more relaxing,
and we could all use to relax.
Fuck.
I know.
I can't,
God dammit.
I can fucking use to relax.
Oh wait.
People are coming together in a big hurry.
Hurry,
hurry to relax.
Yeah,
they're in a hurry.
Hurry up rocks.
Or I don't only have an hour getting there quick and we give him two hours for
40 bucks.
That's amazing.
By the way,
you have the best fucking rates,
man.
Nobody has rates like that.
Everybody else is like,
I've heard 50 bucks an hour.
I've heard people saying,
well you know,
there's no money in this,
there's no profit in it.
So it's,
we have to charge this much just to keep the doors open.
But what you've always done is a,
I mean I can't tell you how many people have gone to the full lab and with dude,
it was so cheap.
I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
And comparing,
like in my town,
it's 150 bucks for an hour.
Like I've heard that,
I've heard 150 bucks for an hour.
It's the most expensive.
You ever heard someone charges?
Can I know buck 20 and stuff?
I don't see it just,
it pumps me out because it's not cool to charge people like that to try to,
you know,
if,
if you,
if she doesn't,
if people said,
oh you're not,
you're gonna charge more.
Well,
so what?
I don't have to,
I don't.
Well,
if you have an initial investment and you build an x amount of tanks and then
you have a place where it makes sense,
like as far as like the amount of rent and then you just have them filled all
day long.
It can be profitable.
I mean you're not going to be Rockefeller not going to,
but you're not trying to do that.
You're just trying to express this shit.
I'm trying to accommodate the people in general.
Not a specific group of people.
Like I remember when he said the clubs,
I always have the Jello shooters for doll.
I have a dollar brew a beer,
always a dollar drafts are always,
and then I have dollars.
Shit.
All My synopsis is a dollar,
you know,
cause the people that the money is a thing for you.
You're dealing with regular.
You want to have,
what is your objective?
Are you trying to make,
is this your money thing?
Are you trying to provide a service and and create equations?
Like does it come to you?
Like,
I never hear anybody.
I've never once heard anybody go do your thing and go,
you know what?
Crash was rude.
The place sucked.
The tanks were expensive.
No one's ever said that.
They always say,
oh crashes.
So cool.
The place is so nice.
I love it there.
It's great.
Like no,
no one has any negativity.
Well that's,
that's like Ian.
So handsome looking them over there.
Beautiful Bastard.
They come and stop girls.
I like that.
Oh,
that's good move.
She,
Ian Should Be oiled up and shirtless.
You'd track dudes and girls.
Is that you have people coming in from all around to use those tanks?
Did he didn't use his tank?
Yeah.
Oh Hey.
That's another thing.
We have your old chamber.
I want to give it away.
We,
uh,
we updated that thing.
It's all black now.
We made the intro,
we changed the door out.
Now it's a,
it's a black door and it's,
it's inlaid and we've taken,
we've fixed it all up.
Oh,
that's awesome.
So something with it.
Let's do that.
Let's,
um,
tell me what we need to do and we'll uh,
we'll give it away.
Thus,
cause I gave away my last tank.
Yeah.
My Somani tank.
I,
uh,
I had a random drawing online.
People send me their emails and I just went,
I spun my,
like fit the thing with my,
uh,
my laptop and I'm like,
okay,
this guy.
And then I just sent it to that guy,
just total random,
decided to send it to this one guy in San Diego and he got my tank.
Well,
this is shipped it to him.
We tuned it all up.
It's an not religious vehicle,
man.
It's,
it's a cool Rick and it's uh,
you know,
it's your old thing.
So is it,
how much does the salt cost?
Uh,
it's funny about that to you.
So you get,
you thinking about the Epson salt may needs himself fake USP grade,
right?
Yes.
It depends on where you get it at.
Even though it's labeled the same way.
USP is a pharmaceutical grade.
There's a quality is different.
Like is there anyway you could get it at the home?
I mean,
at the bed bath and B or a 99 cent store for 50 cents a pound.
Right.
It's not the highest grade,
even though you got to get it from you,
you hook me up with some chemical company.
Got It with right.
Yeah.
And it's like 75,
80 cents a pound or something there,
which is,
you know,
but so I figure it's like a thousand pounds.
It's like 800 bucks.
But the,
that chamber though isn't,
it is in Primos shape.
We have it all fixed up and one day we'll figure out what we're going to do.
Cause you know,
we're,
we're going to be talking more about this,
uh,
this venue in Westwood.
Yeah.
So you're going to open up a place in Westwood.
When is it going to be open for the public?
Good question.
We've been working on it for a while now because of the,
uh,
a few,
details with people that we needed to,
uh,
get behind.
How many tanks do you have right now in Venice to two.
That's it.
Wow.
And uh,
take place in Westwood a little,
have 10,
10.
Oh,
so two w in Venice are booked up like deep into August,
right?
Yes.
And would be if you've probably had 20 of them,
you know,
he turned up,
there's a lot of calls.
We don't make an effort to,
uh,
utilize,
any,
you know,
like there's been some shows on the TV shows wanting to come in and we haven't
even been able,
we don't have any time.
Right.
So it's like saying,
oh,
they want to come and film there or something.
Well,
vice film there,
that was cool.
And Hamilton Morris,
I remember he contacted me after it was over.
He said it was one of the most life changing things he's ever done.
He ate a pot edible and got into your tank and it's just like changed his world.
Well,
it changed our world too.
That really,
uh,
was,
it was mix.
What is an extraordinary opportunity for us then to,
uh,
to,
have the chance to show some people what this was about.
He,
he informed a lot of people,
you know,
uh,
you and him and other people that,
you know,
that mostly it's just you and me.
I Dunno who else has really been,
well,
that was his first jaunt.
Yeah,
his first real run in the tank.
But he's his whole thing that Pharmacopia show that he does really was
fascinating.
He got a lot of really fascinating episode episodes,
really cool.
Um,
well produced episodes where they covered a lot of different kinds of
psychedelics,
a lot of different kinds of subjects.
But this,
this subject,
this,
um,
this whole thing where people are getting curious about altered states of
consciousness is increasing and growing and even more so this idea that you
could do it in something like the tank where it's totally natural and safe and
healthy,
you know,
don't worry about it.
And so I think,
uh,
I think it's all part of,
um,
this new sort of expanding of our ideas that we're seeing in today's society.
It's an expanding of what,
what is,
you know,
what do you have in your life?
What's in your world,
you know,
what are you adding to your body?
What are you adding to your day?
How are you expanding your consciousness,
your point of view.
These are all new things to new,
new,
uh,
considerations.
These are points to consider that in the past we really haven't been left up to
the individual.
It's mostly like you go along with the tide,
you know,
but now you can,
you could grab a hold of yourself and say,
listen to him and I'm in a,
I'm going to think about this the way I think about it and then make the
decisions to,
you know,
have a B,
you're not a victim anymore.
You know,
I was a victim.
All their this,
their that Ah,
you know,
they are what they are,
but you now you with the ability to recognize your,
you know,
that you,
you are capable and that you are,
uh,
potentially,
just getting started.
I mean,
we're all young.
Uh,
if we want to be,
if you want to be certainly all a work in progress and you know,
let's hope the more you keep improving yourself,
the more you enjoy this process of life.
So we were talking about like,
people like try and pull out these people love trying new shit.
You know,
I get into archery recently.
It's fun.
It's like something exciting about learning something,
you know,
you don't know that much about it and you can see your progress,
maybe you know,
take up a martial art or a sport or a skill.
Yeah.
Something that you can start doing something
sewing.
I mean,
I don't know anything.
I mean the uh,
you know,
uh,
it's,
it's good to have a balance.
Yeah.
It is.
It's a,
it's super,
super important to have a balance and also to find things in your life that
stimulate you.
The more things that I do that excite me and stimulate me,
the more things that I do where I'm learning new stuff,
you know,
it's just,
I get into things and they,
those things that I get into wind up enriching my life.
The enthusiasm that I get from pursuing some new subject that I meant.
Cool.
When you're learning what you want to learn about,
which is why I wanted to talk
to you about these crazy screens that you're trying to hook up these tanks with.
This is the thing that crash was going off about forever was the screens that
would suspend above the tank and admit the lowest amount of light possible so
that you only saw the image,
he didn't see the actual screen itself or the border itself.
You just saw the image in front of you and in that sensory deprivation state or
the only input it was coming in was what you were catching off the screen and
what you were hearing from the program that your mind would be way more easily,
way more able to absorb the information.
It's a trip after five tries.
Military providers would use to get this thing finally doing what it's supposed
to do anyway is it had been difficult to get it to be contained.
That image in that area that it has to be on with Fort.
So that that was very,
because you know you're laying down looking at it and one of the first things
that we figured out was because you're on your back is up there.
So He'd take it and you go like this and you go oop.
And as soon as the screen changes around,
you're convinced that you're standing on your feet and looking forward on your
feet at the screen.
Really?
Oh,
this is one of the first things.
And then there's some other stuff there that you know that,
so when you're lying on your back and you watching the video,
you think that you're standing up,
right?
Do you take the video that you make them?
There is no video for this really,
because it's like mostly your brain.
You don't want to see a gone with the wind or,
or you know,
it your,
your whole mind.
Yeah.
Yes.
Patterns or movements or whatever.
We've been working with different stuff as much as we can with the time.
We don't have enough time,
but when we come back,
we have a,
we have a strategy then to start to produce these programs involved in,
uh,
the system.
But the,
uh,
the initial,
what's occurring there with that is a,
and then,
you know,
that's a,
that's the future future.
You see this what we explain it though,
there's a screen that's hovering over your face.
Ah,
how when you're laying on your back,
how wide is it?
It's a,
the one we have now is 19 inches because they,
uh,
material required to build it.
They can't get it any bigger.
Now though,
there's 32 inch screen material.
I can get it to make the,
uh,
to make it 32 inches across.
But is there a size that it's no longer good because you have to go to the
blackboard?
It's all black.
So it was a whole thing as a screen.
But the,
the,
the image,
we'll move around within the screen.
So you have it all black.
We working on something,
you know,
like those tiles in the bottom.
So if you're in a now and you're laying them back on your dome and those tiles
are underneath you so that the bottom is waterproof of course.
But you use the lights on the bottom,
a projector or whatever,
you know,
and on the bottom in a dome,
you're laying on your back and the dome then is all filled in with a screens.
Oh,
and the bottom.
So now you're laying in this thing and you're flying through space and a dumb
the upside everywhere you look and then it flips you over.
But wait a minute.
Wait,
but you can see you can't see through the water.
Yeah,
it's clear as a bell.
So,
but wouldn't that ruin the whole idea of sensory deprivation?
It was new.
It's a whole nother thing underneath you to see light.
You're flying but you can't turn behind you and look behind you.
If it's screen everywhere,
you're enclosed.
And this is,
I don't really want to,
but if you're lying,
I'm confused.
Sorry.
Yeah,
he keeps interrupting cause you're lying on your back.
You're looking up,
right.
What difference does it make?
What's behind you?
You're not going to see that.
Well,
you want to know that it's not.
It's something because then you're flying,
you're suspended,
you look around,
you're in the air.
I mean underneath you is cool too.
If you can have the whole thing and compass,
then you wind up looking up.
But you can't.
When you're aligned back like that,
you don't know which way is up or down.
No,
you would be,
it would make you think that you're on your stomach looking up at what's,
you know,
I mean looking down that what's actually up.
You don't,
your mind is twisted.
When it twists,
you have no reference.
So when the move you in there,
you are under the impression that's the position you're in.
Well,
sometimes I don't know where I'm at when I'm in the tank,
when I sort of snap out of it.
Did you ever move?
I don't even know where my feet are facing.
That's the bottom ever fallen out or anything like that where you take off any
which way or anything.
But yeah,
you feel like you're flying through space so you know that kind of stuff.
It's like freaky be can't tell people about it because they're going,
hey,
10 well you do it.
I think they froze me out because I used to talk too much about stuff.
That was probably those.
Who's they?
I don't know who they are.
The fucking government man.
Every 51 I,
those guys don't have nothing to do with me.
I,
I'm more of a GSA,
but they're controlling.
You would chem trails,
spraying it in the sky box up there.
It's dripping down and then nano stuff now.
That's what,
weird stuff,
Huh?
Oh we won't go there.
Don't go there.
The thing has to do with the audio.
Mostly the audio is what's the yes.
And the audio actually made you at some demonstrations where it made the water
moves.
Oh,
the water's moving.
I said SIGNMADEK frequencies,
we've figured out how to them to create the patterns of sound.
See were made out of a frequency based material.
Maybe you bro,
I made a twisted steel sex appeal.
Is there as an audit file made out frequencies?
Like what do you mean c based materials?
Everything is,
it's moving.
Oh you mean like string every,
the idea of everything moving at a different vibration is comprised of materials
then that are,
you know,
unique.
Like your liver is different than your,
uh,
your kidney,
you know,
the frequency of that deliver or the material that the kidneys made out of.
It'd be different.
So the cells then
that would be,
uh,
used for these purposes would,
if you could,
uh,
see what they tell you,
is that the replication of the cell crazy depreciated version in other words,
as you chosen,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
Okay.
Well,
what if instead of a depreciated version of the previous one,
what if you did better?
What if you created a cell that was a better why?
Why wouldn't you,
if you already understood that?
Well,
this is going to be a tool.
We have the sensors now see I was talking about the brain thing that Germans are
getting me with a cap.
That was the neurons,
the brain thing.
But there's a cap that has the electrodes on it.
Like a swimming cap.
Well,
it's,
it's not diving camp.
Nope.
It's got electrodes on it.
It's a cap that goes on in your head.
Okay.
They haven't built it for me yet,
but I've discussed it with them and they understand that they can do it based on
some testing they've done in a bathtub somewhere.
But the,
uh,
these sensors,
then you see as they're connected to you,
you input information.
See that's the other thing is a sensory of,
of what's going out and what's going into you and then monitoring what occurs
based on this input.
It's,
this is what that thing is all about.
But you know,
I didn't want to get too deep into it cause it's kind of like in the future
right now.
And then
Diaz to combined sound with images to essentially tune your body to a different
frequency and that could potentially change the way your body produces cells.
Absolutely.
That's a Whoa,
yeah.
Interesting analogy of the situation.
But indeed,
uh,
there is a lot of evidence to a,
you know,
and the mind and the effect on the mind,
the physical effect on the brain and that what is meditation?
It's tuning into a certain type of frequency.
I turn a certain type of mindset turning into a certain mentality,
tuning into a certain energy that the mind is,
is focused on and that that actually has a profound effect on the brain itself.
That's pretty interesting stuff.
Oh,
super interesting.
So that makes something like what you're saying actually viable.
Oh yeah.
Now that we have a group of people that are willing to,
uh,
give us the money for that,
you know,
that's,
uh,
we have the resources now to complete that,
you know,
in some sort of period of time.
Once we,
uh,
focus back to it,
we've been trying to get this other stuff done so then we could get back to this
stuff.
But that technology that we've built and patented as well is extraordinary.
And that,
that takes this thing to another level.
I mean,
this is what it is and that's why it's so important as well.
These vehicles that we're producing now,
not only will they be used for this,
uh,
you know,
stuff that we've been talking about here in regards to the relaxation and so
forth else.
It will eventually in the future be used also for,
uh,
you know,
other health benefits and,
uh,
learning and,
a whole array of,
uh,
various,
positive features that this thing is the benefits of.
It absolutely influenced the,
the,
the human,
uh,
and to be used in conjunction with a lot of other things in your life,
proper diet,
exercise,
meditation,
all these things just started to lutely that is this,
there is no,
they say,
oh,
this silver bullet.
It's a,
it's a,
uh,
con like you have to get,
you should be,
everything is important.
Food,
your intake,
their mind,
your,
your rest or whatever it is.
It's all like that.
If you could get yourself,
you know,
balanced out and,
uh,
we have a lot of room for growth and you know,
like I said,
we're just getting started as a,
I think that the,
the species itself,
uh,
humans that we are,
are just starting to understand a little bit about what we are.
We don't know where we came from.
It's a very good point.
Yeah.
Starting to understand.
We'd discussed it in the previous podcast about the,
just the,
just the couple of generations between us,
the people that lived in the 1940s during World War One,
world war two rather than dropping in the first atomic bomb.
And then the people before that,
they in the 18 hundreds,
it's just a few generations.
You just dealing with a few seconds
now how this retina works,
you've seen this in the back of the head.
It's in the dark or the eyes.
They changed it around the information somehow and it comes out there and then
you think it's out there when it somehow back in here being interpretated.
Well,
what we were talking about earlier with meditation,
there's a study,
um,
if you,
uh,
if you Google how meditation changes your brain.
A neuroscientist explains,
there was a,
a group of Harvard neuroscientist led bar.
This woman Sarah Liz are,
who's a phd and they,
uh,
they were interested in mindfulness meditation and they reported that the brain
structures,
they monitored brain structures change after only eight weeks of meditation
practice,
eight weeks of meditation practice.
And your brain starts branching out in a different way.
It starts truly expanding your consciousness.
You think of expanding your consciousness being some sort of an airy fairy
thing.
Well,
no,
it's measurable.
It's expanding your mind itself.
What is more important than this?
I don't think there's anything more.
I mean,
I,
it is the,
it's the premier opportunity yeah.
To,
to,
to do something for yourself.
And if you can expand your mind,
believe me,
all these people that are trying this,
if they tried it in a tank,
it would be,
oh,
so much more effective.
It's a,
it's,
it takes so much.
It's like,
you know,
can you,
uh,
you know,
can you get across the country a riding a bike?
You certainly can.
Can you get across faster if you ride a plane?
Fuck yeah.
Okay.
And this is the difference.
It's like you can get there on a bike.
You certainly can.
Good luck.
Call it techno shamanism,
you know,
technology to,
to,
to create these monks.
They're out there trying to get these two levels.
Is that 20 years in a side of a mountain meditating or you could go jump in a
chamber and get yourself sorted out and uh,
you know much faster.
Well,
yeah,
I mean I would like to see,
see
what those coons Daleney masters when they hit that highest level because I do
believe that they can achieve psychedelic states.
Oh No,
I couldn't lean people.
I don't know they are,
but there's some of those monks up there and these monasteries or wherever
they're at,
they use these frequencies that they produce with their,
uh,
their routes and stuff to affect them somehow.
Duncan Trussell knows how to do that.
He'll,
he'll,
he can do those chants.
Let's crazy Buddhist chance.
He has a memorize.
It's very freaky when he starts doing it.
Does it take a man just some wire?
Does he go on his mind?
He also,
the freeing aspect of chanting and just the harmonizing and sang all those
things.
He just sort of like get into this state of mind.
It puts you into,
this is vibe.
Dunkin benefited tremendously from the tank though docking is been my friend for
a long time.
And one time way in the past he had a bad breakup called me up from a hotel.
He was at some a hotel.
He's like,
dude,
you know,
my girlfriend just kicked me out.
We had this horrible breakup but just went awful.
And I'm like,
he was living with her.
He's like,
I'm literally homeless.
And I said,
hey,
come live with me.
I kind of an extra bedroom.
So Dunkin came and lived with me and was going into the tank that you designed
and he would go in the tank every day.
He lived with me for like
a few months,
I don't know how many,
maybe four or five.
I don't remember totally until he got back on his feet again.
But he sorted everything out in that tank and he would tell me about it.
He was like,
dude,
he goes,
I just can't wait to get back in that tank.
And every day I just get in that tank and I'm figuring it out more and more.
He's figuring it out.
He's not reading what they have bad or is it,
it goes in there and it figures it out.
I've never met a guy who got his shit in order quicker back,
quicker than from a devastating breakup.
Then Dunkin did was willing to go in there and,
and,
and do the work required to get done with that.
He also realized what had gone wrong,
like really quickly instead of like wallowing in his own self pity or trying to
distort reality to sort of,
um,
just sort of be more easily digestible.
You know,
like that was all her,
she's crazy.
He saw the whole thing on it.
He didn't put any twist on it.
She lost his part in it as well as the other one.
And then from then he went on to become a successful comedian.
I mean,
it's crazy.
It's just like a slow build from there.
He caught,
caught that momentum,
but it was,
a lot of it was based on doing,
going that in that tank,
having those experiences on a daily basis.
It's,
it's a,
it's a fantastic a system for people to then,
uh,
you know,
access themselves.
Yeah.
That,
you know,
the,
the rest of it is,
you know,
it's,
uh,
it's a crapshoot.
You really never know what you're going to run into in there,
but you do always have that opportunity to look at yourself and you know,
and sometimes I don't even do that.
Sometimes I just relax.
Sometimes there are times where like,
you know,
I'll come home and maybe I'll come home from a show and everyone's asleep and I
say,
yeah,
I just need to go in there and chill for a bit and I'll just go in there and
just chill.
Like I'm done.
I'm tired.
I did work,
I did shows,
I,
I did a podcast,
I did some writing and maybe even worked out already too.
I don't have nothing to think about.
I just want to chill.
And so I go in there and it just,
uh,
just took out loading man less this,
the,
the lightening of the load,
the releasing of all those muscles and the,
I get out of there and I feel so good.
I feel so like calm and chill.
So important man.
It should be everywhere.
They should have him.
Every gym should have,
um,
community centers should have,
I'm school should have them,
university should have him.
It should be just as important as having a basketball court.
You got a basketball court but you don't have a tank.
The fuck you guys cry.
You teaching people shit.
You know,
you need to get a God damn tank room son.
Well,
we're going to go,
uh,
I think that we're going to do what we can do to make that all happen.
You know,
these schools and stuff that these kids are at.
Once again,
uh,
you know,
if,
if things go the way that we hope they go,
uh,
we're all about providing these vehicles for a schools and,
you know,
old people are veterans or these veterans get a lot of benefit out of this tier.
They get that PSD,
whatever it is,
was traumatic stress disorder.
They say that the chamber is the one thing that,
uh,
helps them up.
They're all getting the Kim,
the,
you know,
the medication and so forth.
But other than that,
they don't really have a,
an option,
you know,
this is a thing.
Uh,
that would be a very,
uh,
appropriate to offer these,
these,
uh,
servicemen and women.
They come back and have troubles dealing with,
uh,
the framework of their situation when they get back here a little,
the opportunity to go in there and investigate the,
uh,
you know,
cause it's already done.
You can't go in there and erase whatever it was.
It's bothering you.
But you could go in there and come to terms with whatever it was realizing it
is,
it's done.
It is what it was.
Just like any other problem that people go back to.
I mean,
at some point it's up to you to release yourself from that obligation to get
upset or feel bad about something that didn't go right in the past,
you know?
And uh,
that's a huge
point because people define themselves by the past instead of thinking about who
they are now instead of they still look back at a mistake they made.
And don't just get past that mistake,
grow and learn,
but dwell on it.
I think it defines them.
They still,
worst thing I met some guys,
that band he says is a singers.
I've only met him twice,
two different times,
years later.
Both Times.
He started telling me about the story,
about what happened to him when he was in this.
Anything in this poor guy has gone on these years
and he's still focused on the worst situation that he ever had to live through.
Yeah.
And it's so a attached to it.
Well,
some guys get one break up and they're done.
Some guys,
one breakup in their twenties will tank them for a decade.
I've met guys like that that,
yeah.
You know what came out here with Sally and you know,
she fucking fell in love with her trainer and dude,
Sally still move on.
What is that?
And fucking years ago,
oh,
well,
you know,
changed my life bro.
But target talk,
I was so disappointed I can't trust women anymore.
Oh,
you stupid.
Fuck.
You know what if he got mugged by one person who'd done trusting people.
Exactly.
I mean,
one person was a murderer.
Let's not trust anybody.
Yeah.
You know,
I heard about Ted Bundy.
I'm not trusting people anymore.
Oh,
okay,
great.
I'm not sleeping tonight.
We,
yeah,
I mean there's definitely pitfalls in life.
You're going to run into him.
We all are.
No,
you can learn and grow.
If you survive,
you pick yourself up,
you dust the dust off and then you start going,
yeah,
no,
you don't let this stuff.
Uh,
don't let it beat you down.
It's also directly proportionate to the amount of hardships that people face in
life,
their ability to face hardships.
You know,
and there's a lot of folks that live life on a cushy cloud of marshmallows and
bullshit.
And then one day something goes wrong.
And I mean,
that's why spoiled kids are so sad.
Like a spoiled young boy is one of the saddest things ever.
A young boy that becomes a man and can't take care of himself and his dad has to
keep on rescuing him.
His Dad has to keep on bailing them out of situations and giving them money.
I've met guys like that and that is a crippling affliction when they don't have
the character themselves to be able to get by in life.
They constantly need someone to help them and bail them out.
Even as a grown man,
I've met guys in their forties,
it's still need help from their parents.
I'm like,
what the fuck man,
you're never going to get it right because somewhere along the line they didn't
face enough of the university to realize that there's some times you just got to
get up and get shit done.
There's sometimes we have to fucking pull yourself up and you have to push
forward,
even if you want to stay in the bed.
And if you don't do that and you just keep calling on your daddy and your daddy
keeps rescuing you,
you never developed those tools.
You never develop that ability to recognize what you're doing wrong with your
life because you're,
you're soft.
You got to Cushnie,
you've got a safety net,
a safety net for your safety net.
I have this friend and she has this,
uh,
this friend that she's been friends with for decades and this poor fuck his
family,
super,
super wealthy,
like unbelievable wealthy,
billions of dollars.
And he had that,
not only did he had,
uh,
he had a trust fund and a backup trust fund.
So he blew through the trust fund and then he blew through the backup trust
fund,
real estate investments and just disastrous business ventures.
No character and no discipline,
no ability to stick it out.
But incredible amount of resources.
He had millions and millions of dollars.
Just pissed it all away,
didn't understand it,
completely depressed.
And one day said to her,
he said,
you know,
cause she has children as well and she has sons.
He said to her,
he goes,
whatever you do,
do not give your kids money.
Don't give them a fucking penny.
He goes,
especially your boys.
Don't give him a penny that that ruined me.
Don't give him money then I was,
that's deep shit to be a man like in your late forties looking back at your
life,
this disaster wreckage that you've put forth,
the millions you've blown now he has like a retail job.
His parents fucking abandoned them.
I mean you look at that and you go,
Whoa,
this is,
this is wild shit man.
It's guy is still struggling from the way he was developed from the,
the tools that were instilled in him at a childhood.
And then,
you know,
in adolescence and having that safety net just provided him with a way to stay
in bed,
kept him week,
never developed character now or the,
uh,
have an opportunity.
Every time things go wrong,
every time things feel terrible,
you have an opportunity to learn from whatever makes you feel terrible and never
allow it to happen again.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Thank you.
That's forward.
Don't,
don't do it again.
Yeah.
You know,
learn from your mistakes.
We all make them.
That's where meditation comes in.
Recognizing that and solidifying it in your head and the,
I believe meditation in the tank,
which is a more magnified form of meditation.
I think it's more intense and I think that you can,
you could really get something out of that if with those sort of ideas in your
mind about constant,
consistent improvement and that's the only,
the only thing that you'll allow from yourself is to maintain a certain standard
then consistently trying to improve and do that.
Do that and you'll be,
you'll be a happier person.
That's an amazing concept there to become a part of,
to where you're involved in the Osha instruction of your own character.
Yes.
It's through your own efforts and your own evaluation and then two to make the
right steps and make the right decisions that to become even stronger as you go.
Yeah.
Engineering your life.
It can be done.
You know,
it's not,
it's not impossible.
You can,
I mean,
you can do it to a certain extent,
certain extent.
You can do it.
The world could be a better place crash,
right.
It's becoming a better place to becoming a better place.
Everybody's part there is to do is to hopefully make it a little bit better.
You know,
if we could all get on that,
just threw that together,
try to make things a little bit better,
just a little bit better.
It would really,
uh,
have,
a monstrous of fat.
I agree.
And uh,
I want to thank you.
I want to thank you for coming on the podcast and,
uh,
talking about this stuff and I really want to thank you for being this guy who
was out there innovating in this,
you know,
almost forgotten business because for me,
knowing you has been very important.
It's helped me a lot.
And knowing your tanks and being aware of that,
you know,
there's a guy out there that's pushing it so far,
it's created this incredible portal.
I,
I think of it,
I mean,
I know what it is,
is it's a tank filled with water and I know there's a heater attached and I know
there's filters now,
but for me it's a portal.
I get in that fucking thing and I transform,
I travel,
I go to places.
Yeah,
it does.
It,
it's a mental vehicle.
Takes you somewhere.
Yeah,
it does.
It opens up passages in your mind to take you to some pretty extraordinary
places.
So thank you my brother.
Thank
you Joe.
You've,
you know,
been a monumental in my life and a,
I want to thank you from the bottom of my heart.
Well,
we found each other,
man.
That's,
that's how that's supposed to work,
you know,
we,
we both let people understand,
uh,
what the,
the benefits of these things are and we both benefit from them as well and are
generous with those ideas,
spread those ideas to other people.
Just to let him know,
man,
I'm not making this up.
You can,
you can really get better.
Your life can fuck it.
And the people who,
if you're perfect right now,
who are you?
Who are you?
You strange.
Fuck.
But I really believe everyone way,
not everyone.
Everyone can benefit from that.
Everyone.
So,
uh,
if you guys want to go,
the float lab is a,
is booked up rock solid deep into August.
But um,
the,
the Brentwood one,
who knows what,
we'll be open.
Hopefully Westwood.
Excuse me.
You got to print one Westwood.
What's the difference?
Where's,
where's Westwood?
Ucla.
Okay.
Where's Brentwood?
Brentwood is,
I always confuse those tests.
I just realized,
right,
which one's more posh?
Which one is where?
Um,
Brentwood.
Brentwood is where Oj killed the,
allegedly.
That's real posh.
It's very posh.
Very cost.
That's why I was quite shocking.
I'm not allowed in that neck of the woods.
They don't let you in.
I'll talk to somebody.
Uh,
anyway.
Um,
so we'll,
we'll let you know when a Westwood opens up.
We'll let you know on the podcast and meanwhile you can fall crash,
uh,
on Twitter.
It's the float lab is the a website for,
uh,
for the float lab itself and a,
do you guys have an Instagram too?
Yeah,
we do the Facebook float lab technologies,
float lab technologies on Facebook please like that and follow and all that good
stuff.
And we're going to have that chamber to do something with their,
as soon in the near future,
the cool,
my old chamber,
we'll figure out some sort of a contest and give that bitch away loopy second
time,
have given away a chamber.
I'm very excited about that.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back tomorrow with a full charge.
Matt full tron will be in the house and uh,
that's it.
All right.
Until then,
much love big kiss.